E
[Música]
como eu sem um tostão no bolso Construa
um espaço de fortalecimento da
autoestima
e quantas vezes você deixou de realizar
algo por achar que não tinha os recursos
necessários
qual foi o time vc desistiu de um sonho
eu disse aqui agora nesse exato momento
você tem irmãos tudo o que você precisa
para causar uma transformação do mundo
você acredita Vou te provar que você é
possível preciso contar a minha história
você já sabia que meu nome é Renata que
eu sou fotógrafa mas o que vocês não
sabem é que eu não me via na minha
infância era raríssimo eu achar alguém
parecida comigo algum tipo de
Publicidade em capas de revista jornal
como protagonista de livro eu tinha
pouquíssimas referências e eu fui
crescendo na escola central no grupo da
minoria ou algumas vezes eu cheguei a
ser a única negra na sala de aula na
faculdade de arquitetura a mesma coisa
60 alunos o meu ano dois alunos negros
contando comigo e o fato de não ver
gente parecida comigo sempre me
incomodou profundamente só que eu fui
crescendo tô dando esse incômodo e eu
sempre gostei muito de fotografia então
depois eu conclui a faculdade de
arquitetura Gente eu juro que eu tentei
ser arquiteta mas não deu eu tive que
deixar ela paixão falar mais alto e eu
entendi que a fotografia devia ser
levada como a minha profissão então
durante esse período de transição que
levou uns 2 anos eu estudei e pesquisei
tudo que eu pude sua fotografia eu
fotografei tudo que eu pude também então
fotografia de paisagem de arquitetura eu
vi que isso realmente não era minha
praia eu precisava de alguém do outro
lado da lente Engraçado que no começo a
sonhava com essas fotografias de
paisagem né vida selvagem só que não era
para mim
e tem um ser humano Apesar lente me
atraía muito mais então eu descobri eu
gostava de fotografar gente e eu fui
tomando gosto por fotografar mulheres
gestantes mães tudo que ela acionada
esse mundo feminino e eu comecei a me
questionar a onde estavam as mulheres
negras as famílias no trabalho esses
outros colegas Será que o pessoal não
consumia fotografia porque a impressão
que eu tinha é que a gente simplesmente
não existia no trabalho do outro quando
encontrava alguma modelo Parecia que ela
estava ali para cumprir um papel sabe
era aquela modelo exótica o que tinha o
cabelo diferente para Será diferente ali
do grupo
porque na publicidade os negros não
estavam na minha infância e até hoje
continuo sendo um pouco apresentados eu
pesquisei para mim falar com vocês isso
é 38 por cento da publicidade no Brasil
é representado por pessoas brancas até
hoje e a gente tá no país que a gente
tem a maior população negra fora da
África então gente essa com e fecha e
aquele incômodo que eu carregava foi
ficando cada vez maior foi ficando um
suportável e eu precisava fazer alguma
coisa porque eu tinha que agir então eu
criei essa reparação visual eu queria
mostrar para todo mundo tudo que eu
cresci não vendo mas eu sabia que estava
ali sendo invisibilizado e foi daí que
nasceu o projeto alguns o lugar onde
mulheres negras seriam retratadas mas
como protagonistas e angústia uma
palavra em umbundu que é um idioma uma
língua do Sul de Angola e essa língua
essa palavra significa força poder e por
mais que eu saiba que é injusto por mais
que eu acho que eu acredite quem justa a
gente ser forte o tempo todo é de certa
forma necessário porque se mulher e ser
mulher negra no Brasil em qualquer parte
do mundo é Um Desafio diário e aqui vão
alguns fatos para quem ainda não
entendeu porque das minhas escolhas a
mulher negra é que possui a menor o
ativo de vida é a que recebe o menor
salário e a que mais sofre violência
obstétrica e infelizmente eu poderia
continuar essa lista de desvantagem por
muitos e muitos minutos mas eu vou parar
por aqui
eu entendi que se eu quisesse alguma
mudança por menor que fosse eu precisava
pegar para mim essa responsabilidade e
começar alguma coisa já que desde a
minha infância nada tinha mudado isso
não é raro para pensar quantos projetos
e ações sociais vocês conhecem que são
liderados ou criados por alguém que tem
pouco recurso financeiro e eu tenho
certeza que se vocês puxarem pela
memória vocês vão lembrar de pelo menos
um então vocês lembram quando eu disse
que lá no começo a gente não você já
tinham tudo que vocês precisavam que
dinheiro equipamento infraestrutura tudo
isso vem depois o sonho primeiro a gente
tem que agir muitas vezes a gente
acredita que para fazer um bairro melhor
uma comunidade não precisa de muito
dinheiro e eu não vou mentir o dinheiro
é sempre muito
é só que isso tudo bem Depois da gente
agir um motor da mudança é ação e não
existe a nave dá para gente começar
alguma coisa O começo nunca vai ser
perfeito a gente aprende muita coisa no
caminho e o que que eu tinha em mãos um
incômodo constante e Crescente um sonho
de ver mais mulheres parecidas comigo
nas ruas uma câmera e e o Instagram
Então finalmente colocar tudo em prática
eu precisava do número grande de modelo
e naquele ano alguns meses antes de eu
pôr o projeto em prática foi um ano para
abrir uma empresa em empresa de
fotografia Então ninguém me conhecia
então eu tive que me explicar muito
muito muito que eu pretendia fotografar
essas modelos ou maneira respeitosa e
depois de muito me explicar e alguns
nãos eu Finalmente consegui me as 30
modelos e no começo a gente simplesmente
não tinha estrutura e eu não tinha
espaço físico e eu trabalhava é o ar
livre como sempre né o trabalho até hoje
então simplesmente marcava o horário um
local a gente ir fotografava e no começo
até me acusaram de ser estranho né eu
levar as modelos para o Mato para fazer
foto delas e durante os meses que
levaram o projeto da organização até a
realização que levou um bom tempo aí daí
eu fui crescendo e as modelos foram
gostando da experiência porque elas não
viram o resultado que ela só viu depois
E aí a ideia foi crescendo Então o que
era para ser um perfil de rede social
acabou virando a exposição fotográfica e
mesmo de maneira muito modesta no final
de tudo isso ela aconteceu mas foi
durante os ensaios que é magia da
fotografia aconteceu e a Magia esse
momento de entrega sabe que a gente
deixa de ser visto pelos olhos dos
outros é a confiança mas só que nesse
caso era um olhar de respeito e tu já
que eu também sou uma mulher negra e eu
sei tudo o que significa elas gostaram
tanto de todo esse processo que elas
resolveram pagar onde dó que elas estão
se amando tanto e gostar do resultado
que elas queria mostrar para todo mundo
e aí foi daí que veio essa ideia da
gente todo ano é e foi assim até até o
final durante toda a gente levar o
Outdoor do projeto para as ruas e
diga-se de passagem a cidade foi uma
atitude meio inédita ver tanto a mulher
preta no outdoor e logo veio medo também
porque eu pensava Será que alguém além
dos modelos vão tem interesse de ver
esse projeto de ver tudo isso e para
minha surpresa
nessa exposição que eu disse para vocês
foi modesta no primeiro dia e se a gente
abriu oficialmente tinha gente na porta
esperando então foi aí que eu vi a
grandeza da gente dá o primeiro passo no
primeiro ano fotografia e trinta
mulheres no segundo ano foram setenta e
ao longo desses quatro anos foram 105 o
e crianças e o número de inscrição
sempre foi maior Então a partir do
segundo ano sempre ficava gente fora
infelizmente E aí a ideia que surgiu com
o perfil de rede social ao longo dos
anos transformou em outras posições 10
Outdoor e um mural de mais de 15 metros
que foi exposto durante mais um ano
centro da cidade e também foi durante o
caminho que eu encontrei quem me
ajudasse nessa ideia algumas modelos que
se sentiram tocados e vieram fazer parte
da equipe então tudo que começou com uma
equipe de duas pessoas ser meu namorado
depois ao longo do ano foi crescendo e
ele foi cada ano que passava foi
ganhando mais um integrante
inclusive uma delas abriu a própria casa
para se nosso ponto de encontro e isso
sim transformou o projeto e por mais que
esses números sejam positivos para mim O
Mais Importante foi Impacto que se gerou
na vida das pessoas da 150 mulheres que
eu fotografei algumas histórias me
marcaram alguma delas tiveram coragem o
cabelo e deixar ali natural o que não é
uma coisa muito fácil um país a gente
perde emprego a gente sofre racismo por
causa de cabelo Alguma delas se
fotografar um pela primeira vez Então
tinha gente que tinha sonho de fazer
fotos de 15 anos tudo e nunca tinha
feito alguma delas pela primeira vez eu
ouvi esse relato que sentiram bonitas
Alguma delas também usar o turbante pela
primeira vez e se emocionaram com essa
conexão Mas o mais importante para mim o
principal é que para algumas se para
outras né O pai o projeto foi o ponto de
partida para uma transformação muito
grande na vida e esse é o resultado essa
mudança na vida das pessoas Isso sim
para mim foi mais importante
aí agora a pergunta se eu tô rica não
longe disso esse nunca foi o objetivo do
projeto por mais que a fotografia seja
meu ganha-pão de onde eu tiro meu
sustento esse projeto era mais um um
respiro sabe e ele respiro não era mais
um grito porque eu precisava me
expressar e a gente fez muito barulho eu
acho que o objetivo foi cumprido em
dinheiro todo esse movimento essa
transformação sem a gente deu cenário
ideal o que quase ninguém sabe é que eu
sou muito crítica Então para mim o
projeto nunca tava perfeita projeto
nunca foi perfeito eu sempre a seguinte
podia melhorar nos outros anos e o
projeto só parou por conta da pandemia
mas só que Talvez ele volte porque eu
continuo inconformada e o que te move o
que te deixa inconformado a falta de
representatividade me fez a construir
meu espelho e a minha ferramenta foi a
fotografia eu quero que você seja um
conformado também porque hoje a gente
tem o poder de criar espaços que nos
carvão de maneira rápida e eficiente as
redes sociais na internet estão aí para
isso Agora me diz qual que é a sua
ferramenta para mudança que você quer
ver no mundo
bom obrigada viu
[Música]